[Music]
everything takes away I know very few
geniuses very few if any who can just
show up and be brilliant the rest of us
we have to work hard there there is no
magic potion there is no secret sauce
it's work and it's a lot of work and not
to be afraid of work but indulge in it
take it be confident with it work hard
there are certain things that come in
time you know and experience is one of
those things that comes after time you
you need the time but you can put
yourself in a position to gain
experience by allowing yourself to
voluntarily be a beginner at something I
find that to be a very big character
trait very admirably character trait
when someone purposefully puts them in
the selves in a position to be a
beginner so the CEO of a major
corporation says you know I don't know
how to snowboard I'm going to go out
there and and this person man or woman
who is a commander of legions of people
perhaps is now on on the side of a
mountain falling on his or her ass and
having a sixteen-year-old kid be the
teacher that's a fantastic position to
put yourself in and I think people
should constantly look for ways to
voluntarily put themselves in a position
of not knowing of being vulnerable of
saying I'm gonna learn something here I
want to be open to this and admit I
don't know how to snowboard please teach
me and and have an experience and
empowering a millennial a younger
generation person to say you are my
instructor you are my teacher please do
it and it's like wow that's a beautiful
thing for human beings to share is to
reach out and say no you're the boss
please show me the way there's power and
confidence I'm on the other side of the
the table now a lot I produce and I
direct and I write and I can really feel
the difference when someone comes into a
room with confidence but I want to draw
the distinction between confidence and
boastfulness someone who is figuratively
pounding their chest saying how great
they are
that's not confidence to me that's it's
egocentric behavior and that makes me
push away someone who boasts about how
great they are I'm leery about that but
there's a quiet confidence and what I
try to to express to Millennials to
younger generation of actors writers
directors artists of any kind is to is
to value your talent and I would say to
them I'd say are you talented and I hope
you say yes that's not a boast it's it's
being honest do you go out and tell
everybody on the street
hey I'm talented I'm really talent no
it's for yourself it's it's it's
internal and you can own that and you
can value greatly value your own
contributions to something your
intellect your imagination your humor
whatever experience you have so far
you're young you'll gain more experience
that's great
be confident in that when I sense
confidence I want more from that person
I I do the reaching
and I think that's a great lesson I just
came back from a USO tour and talking to
only Millennials and you know
Millennials have been maligned a lot
thinking that you know you've been
you've been given the line of
oh you just want the trophy you just
want to show up and you'll get a trophy
you're not really willing to work for it
you're not and that I just don't buy
into that just don't listen to any of
that I was so impressed with these young
men and women in the military in this
case commanding great presence
confidence nobility kindness my wife and
I said I think we're gonna be okay truly
it's like oh if this is if this is the
next generation of leaders we're gonna
be okay
we really are we're gonna be fine you
know I think every generation looks to
the next one and says oh they're not
like us we were better than that you
guys are fine but there is there is
definite value in work I knew that when
I was starting out as an actor I was all
about work it was like I still AM
I love it but that's the that's the key
if if you find something that you love
to do then when Monday comes along
you're not going Monday you're like
Monday I get to act that was great for
me I love Mondays get to love Mondays
[Music]
you